depuis combien de temps êtes-vous
gardienne de ce farde mademoiselle le
bail depuis 39 ans Monsieur mais dites
moi c'est une vocation familiale je
crois ah oui parce que mon grand-père il
a allumé le premier en 1855 je suis né à
Dick et là-bas j'ai vu une frange et ça
m'a toujours donné l'idée de gardienne
de phare pour allumer les feux pour que
les mains évitent les écueils vous fumez
beaucoup
en effet
qui me faisait veiller toute la nuit
est-ce que vous avez d'autres
occupations maintenant que avec
l'électricité c'est quand même plus
simple je m'occuperai un peu de stricule
je crois que je dois cesser l'année
prochaine à 75 et là dites-vous et là
j'espère que mon neveu va me
remplacera et on me laisse un petit
logement ça va être le jeune quitterai
pas le phare ça me changera pas beaucoup